the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers based on the book everyone's
mom read on the beach comes the best
acted coolest looking most well-written
Lifetime movie ever made
gone girl meet Nick and Amy - successful
good-looking people in love
she's the basis for a beloved series of
children's books his amazing aim and
he's a caring son who moves to Missouri
to take care of his sick mother they
seemed like the perfect couple but
there's just one problem
she's batching crazy
settle in for the film that had
audiences everywhere wondering if their
significant other was planning to kill
them in this cold-hearted look and how
all men are pigs or how all women are
monsters or both either way you probably
shouldn't see it on the first date I
picture cracking her lovely skull
unspooling her brain's Ben Affleck stars
as a guy everyone loves to hate it look
like
King Ashley when his wife Amy disappears
he'll respond by acting as guilty as
humanly possible because she told me to
and banging the hot chick from the
blurred lines video hmm
blurred babes Rosamund Pike shines as
the most well organized crazy person
ever a murderer who's sick and tired of
acting cool just to please a man
even though unlike the book we never see
or do anything cool ever
all we did was thank each other how to
control each other that's marriage
follow along as she escapes her cheating
husband by creating fake money troubles
befriending the local pregnant idiot so
she can steal her pee to fake a
pregnancy staging a crime scene with
gallons of her own blood
creating a five-year diary of fake a few
stories then planning to kill herself so
she can frame him for her murder
instead of I don't know divorcing him
seems a lot easier to me experience the
film critics are still debating for
being either pro or anti feminist even
though its message boils down to don't
have sex with crazy people a lesson the
Neil Patrick Harris clearly didn't pay
attention to a girl is allowed to be
crazy as long as she is equally hot they
want a girl to be above this line oops
witness director David Fincher at the
height of his powers as he reveals each
twist and turn with his trademark
Ventura's ohms like smooth camera pans a
cool color palette a dank abandoned
building
nihilism life I don't run the point
sociopaths loaded interiors ambient
music A's and general fitness wait she
putting that in her oh man this movie is
messed up so settle in for a nearly
three hour movie that will keep you on
the edge of your seat full of
manipulations murder and a seat until
Ben Affleck finally gets his revenge by
staying with her to start a family
what why would he do that
Ron dude and is this dick what is
happening means ending is weird
starring Adnan Syed chasing amy mad a of
the movie for was SafeSearch off Doogie
Howser Nancy Grace and still almost
famous your wife probably wants to kill
you that's where you two animals people
I've ever known this movie really could
have used more Tyler Perry oh did I
really just say that
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers hey screen junkies ever
wondered if you could do the impossible
then check out Amy's new show epic how
to where they show you how to do
kick-ass things like win an Oscar so get
started by clicking the box above and
tell'em screen junkie sent you the epic
voice hereby smite you genesis does what
an intent don't they hate us cuz they
anus pushy big bumble snazzle the line
must be drawn here no further heed my
shorts
Chewbacca Maggie